attention maybe focused on the race to
succeed Jeremy Corbyn as Labour leader
but five candidates are now through to
the final stage of the contest to become
the party's new deputy leader Christina
alençon in Murray Richard Burgin and the
front-runner Angela Reina are all
through along with the shadow women and
equality secretary dawn Buckland and I'm
pleased to say she joins us now in the
studio well thank you very much for
being in the studio with us this morning
and you've got very busy schedule with
all the hustings it is all over the
country so what's your pitch then to be
deputy leader well I have a strategy and
a plan it's called a chord strategy
cor IDI campaign organized recruit
educate and D for discipline which is
the new one that I added as I've been
going around the country I am the most
experienced candidate I've served under
to labor prime ministers and in jeremy
corbyn's Shadow Cabinet and I am the
unity candidate I've got the temperament
to work with everybody and I've worked
with everybody all the MPs in Parliament
and right now we need somebody who's
going to bring the whole party together
and I'm that person I mean a lot of this
is 20 pick out what went wrong last time
Labour's worst defeat at an election
since 1935 why do you think labour did
so badly at the loss action so it was a
devastating defeat but there's two
things there's an autopsy that's
currently going on as to why we lost
there are a number of MPs and trade
unions who are getting together to look
at the detail of that but while we're
doing that it shouldn't stop us for
having a strategy to win and so what I'm
doing is ensuring that we implement my
strategy to win so it was wrong you have
to work out why you're lost I know it
will run in parallel but we know the
reasons why we lost and there are many
reasons but whilst they're working that
out this strategy of campaigning
organize in recruiting educating and the
discipline in the party is a structure
that will ensure that we prepare for
power and we're on the road to winning
and that is and that is vital and in
fact as a deputy leader that would be my
focus so as I say the autopsy will take
time but whilst they're taking time it
shouldn't stop us
for preparing to win at the next general
why do you think labor law selection
that well we have to campaign all year
round we have to have community
campaigning on the ground we weren't
doing that we were putting in organizers
but very late in areas and that leads to
change and from day one as mayor deputy
leader
I wish or ensure that that does change
we need to be better organized we need
to have message discipline we have
technology that work there's a lot of
technology that didn't work we need to
have better structure we had need to
have a strategy to win I will ensure
that all of that is implemented and my
watch so that campaign was to blame not
the message and your vehicle there's a
number of things it's not just the
campaign what I'm saying is we need to
campaign all year round we haven't been
doing that effectively as a Labor Party
the counselors have been in some areas
and we need to campaign and make sure
that we have joined up campaigning and
that is vital if we are going to win
that is vital if we are going to build
trust in communities and that's exactly
what I would implement on day one of me
because other than deputy leader other
than campaigning all year round why do
you think they were lost because it
can't just be that I mean it was the
worst defeat since 1935 there were a
number of elements a number of reasons
and as I've said so if you there will be
this autopsy that's taking place but
whilst that but whilst that's happening
what we need to do and what my role is
as deputy leader will be is to ensure
that we have a structure and a strategy
in place we don't have that we didn't
have a structure in place we didn't have
a proper strategy in place and the
messaging of delivering a manifesto was
too complex and it was just too detailed
and there was too much of it I called it
the Toby carvery of the manifesto there
was just too much on the plate and we
have to take our time to explain it in
bite-size chunks in the next three to
five years gives us an opportunity to
allow that to happen and that's why the
court strategy is key to labor winning
at the next election and for us building
trust Jeremy Corbyn a problem as I say
like it's not this isn't about blame or
dissecting all of the aspects of why we
lost we lost and it was a devastating
lost so what we need to do now is
prepare to win and prepare for the power
Jeremy Corbyn is now stepping down
as a leader of the Labour Party so he
will no longer people upon the doorsteps
what we need to do now is focus and the
focus and the laser focus is winning
you know I am I'm a winner and I want to
focus on winning and that's why the
court strategy is absolutely key to
labour winning and get him back into
power and getting him to number 10 as I
said I've served under two Labour Prime
Minister's and I want to serve under
another okay and now one of the things
that the next step she leader of the
Labour Party will have to focus on is
anti-semitism and the allegations of
Labour's handling of anti-semitism that
dog shoe ahead of the last election now
the Board of Deputies of British Jews
have asked all the leadership and deputy
leadership candidates to sign up to
pledges you're one of only two
candidates not to do that mm-hmm why
haven't you because there are certain
things that needs to happen so we have
being investigated by the EHR see the
Equality of human rights commission it's
not something to be proud of but we are
being investigated and you're the party
they arrest it was the MP MP so it's
nothing to be proud of by the end of the
day we have committed and I've said that
what we need to do is ensure that all of
the recommendations from that
investigation gets implemented so we're
going to do that first and then there
I've written to the border deputies in
order to have a meeting with them to
discuss a few of the recommendations or
any that you have a problem with because
reading and it feels as if these are
things that people shouldn't necessarily
have a boat yeah no there was a couple
of things which you haven't got all the
detail on this you've only got the
headline facts but I agree that we need
to have an independent disciplinary
process but part of what the Board of
Deputies has are supposed to see some of
the disciplinary cases now if you've got
an independent process you then can't
give your disciplinary cases to an
outside body there's not affiliated to
the Labour Party that's against the GD P
R so I've asked to sit down with the
Board of Deputies so that we can have a
discussion about that and engage with
community via Maine Jewish groups and we
also have to engage with everybody it's
not for me to tell the Jewish community
what they want to do we need to engage
with all of the Jewish communities so
absolutely the border deputies are vital
in key so is Jewish labor movement vital
key so the other Jewish labor members
and the Jewish community as a whole at
the end of the day the Labor Party
didn't handle it right at the end of the
day we were slow in reacting and slow in
act and in acting and you know we all
should take responsibility for that and
what we need to make sure that we do is
that we get it right and in some places
it's very important that crest doesn't
at you that you've been too slow to
react to what the Jewish community is
asking for man do you think that you
know better
I don't know absolutely it's not about
knowing better I mean at the end of the
day we have to have a procedure and a
process that works for everyone that
doesn't just work for the Jewish
community but it works for the black
community it works for women it works
for disabled people they weren't
official you btq the jewish community
feel with the labor party isn't that do
exactly is it certificate so there's an
issue and we have to resolve it and we
have to get it right and getting it
right means that we have to do it in a
comprehensive way that works for
everyone
there's no hierarchy of discrimination
so we have to deal with it and we have
to make sure it's right and that's why
the HRC report that the Board of
Deputies has said that we must commit to
implementing is vital we haven't seen
that report yet is first of them
published in January it hasn't been
published hopefully we published this
month we get that we implement that we
sit down with the Board of Deputies we
have a discussion with them we sit down
with JLM we have a discussion with them
and we get this right the most important
thing that we get this right we don't
have a blame game that doesn't help the
situation it doesn't help to get it
right it's too important for me to just
tick a box or whatever we have to get
this right it's vital in your statement
when you're explaining why you didn't
want to sign up to these pledges you
were saying and that you endure racism
on a daily basis so you know what it
feels like what do you mean by that
oh my goodness well you all you have to
do is growth through my twitter feed and
you will see the racism you will see the
misogyny you know as a black woman I
suffer you know people attacking me
because I'm a woman people attacking me
because I'm black people attacking me
because I have a voice and I use my
voice and my plan
form and you know people have said you
know what dawn you have to have a thick
skin well I don't want anybody to come
into politics and needing to have a
thick skin I want people to be respected
people talk about the language of
tolerance I don't want to be tolerated
accept me for who I am as a black woman
accept me for the fact that yes
understanding to be deputy leader it's
not an easy thing for me to do it's not
an easy thing for me to put myself out
there as a visible minority but I think
it's important if I'm going to ensure
that other people can come up behind me
and be recognized for who they are and
the skills that they bring to the table
and it's important that you know I fight
for various issues not just that affects
in my community like the windrow scandal
and the charter flight that's you know
accompanied you to leave in five days
time where I have a constituent on that
flight which is a disgrace of this
government but you know I'm going to
hold this government to account for all
of their hostile environment and racism
but I'd also hold them to account on
everything else to do with the country
and making the country better the
working-class people in the country for
women in the country for disabled people
for climate change I'm going to hold
this government to account and as deputy
leader it gives me a platform to do that
even greater we've seen a couple of
cases of black female employees being
mixed up I'm not Marcia Florence your
reaction when you saw that well it is
quite exhausting because it happens
regularly so Marcia and I get confused
quite often sometimes we laugh about it
but sometimes it's important that we
bring it up and we say look at the end
of the day you know it's been over you
know I've been in politics for a number
of years now I first came in in 2015 and
the fact that people are still getting
me confused with other MPs it's actually
a disgrace and it's not about making a
mistake it's about making an effort so
how much are you going to make an effort
to ensure that you can distinguish one
black female MP from another black
female MP and if you've got nobody in
the newsroom who can identify us
individually then find somebody who can
and make sure your newsroom is more
diverse or you have people who can
identify us differently and it's
important for everybody that I feel like
a sense of responsibility
for all of the young African Caribbean
women coming behind me but I also feel a
sense of responsibility for all of the
young black men who just get tagged with
one you know you are a black man and you
fit the description let's get in the
description right and let's top
we are hyper visible of black people but
then as human beings we are invisible
and that needs to change okay and I'm
keen to Oishi and just ended interview
about John Barker now he's been accused
of bullying staff members including by
the former black rod David leaky he said
he brutalized people who work for him
important to circles John Braco denies
these allegations now there are reports
that Jeremy Corbyn is nominating him for
a peerage do you think John back home
should be given a payment I think it is
the norm that the Speaker of the House
is always given a peerage so I think the
first question for me is why hasn't he
been given a period are these probably
allegations from the conservative so
well they haven't said that's the reason
why they haven't given him a period and
I would like to know why is it reason
why he wasn't given a period I suspect
is actually to do with brexit rather
than anything else the other thing is
due process has to happen so if you
accuse somebody of bullying there needs
to be due process I'm a trade union
activist I am very I'm very forceful in
terms of making sure that due process is
followed so if John Burke has been
accused of bullying then there needs to
be due process and has he been found
guilty or is it just an accusation and I
think those are the things that we have
to go through but really do need to ask
the conservatives why is it that you
haven't that you haven't like everybody
else is sure that the Speaker of the
House is given a peerage okay otherwise
I think that's a form of bullying too
and your colleague Diana Baur
sent an deleted a tweet this week that's
received quite a lot of attention and
have a quick look at what she said she
said the allegations about the bullying
come from former parliamentary official
David Leakey he had been a lieutenant
general who served in Germany Northern
Ireland and Bosnia but claims he was
bullied ie
intimidated coerced by John Bercow
unlikely so an acceptable view I think
really you'd have to ask Diane about her
tweet
this is the first time that I'm seeing
it I haven't read it before so it's the
first time that I'm reading it but
really I think Diane needs to come on
and just explain what she means you may
have a good reason for writing that I
don't know but it's unlikely that
someone could be bullied if they had
been in the Army I mean surely anyone
can be bullied anybody could be bullied
at any time I was bullied at work once
and I you know you think that you can't
be bullied and then you're bullied and
that's why I think trade unions are
vital in regards to taking on bullies in
the workplace and that's why I'm
committed to the trade union movement
but as I say you'd have to arts Diana
father okay thank you and very much Don
thanks very much coming on the program
today and setting up a pitch to be the
deputy leader of La Paz a pleasure